[Musique]
quand tu as besoin de moules à l'essai
d'un ami c'est quelqu'un qui veille sur
toi
du denaisis benoît genauzeau 1 qui en
fit qu'à donner les habite pas loin à
des immigrés je les en aurais ça va se
retrouver avec des gens comme ça coince
benoît est mort beaucoup fait il se
retourne dans sa tombe autant qu eux
pour koné plus
j'ai vraiment envie de les aider à
passer au nombre de seize docteur
béatrice alors
tu penses que tu vois tout le relais
dans deux jours c'est mieux tu me la
joues bien tu ramènes eux restés à la
maison six mois c'est encore moi qui
décide qu'il y ait un qui part d'accor
des réfugiés j'espère que tu connais les
risques j'imagine que tu avais quelque
chose
[Musique]
je suis
tu es fatigué jamie choi par sagesse a
toujours contrôlé qui vous avez parce
qu'ils suivent douche bien la peur elle
est là c'est clair que ce n'est pas
clair
[Musique]
je sais plus trop habitués à être
attachés à leurs idées
oh
[Musique]